si es por ello que desde el 13 de
septiembre hasta el 30 de octubre los
estudiantes de este grupo etario entre
los 12 y los 15 años serán inoculados
contra la 19 en todo el país son más de
1.800.000 estudiantes a nivel nacional
que están habilitados para recibir en
las dosis en ecuador que en este caso
será con los laboratorios fighter en una
sola aplicación cuentos dosis con las de
sinovac los estudiantes que tengan
consentimiento de sus padres de igual
forma el 80 por ciento de los
estudiantes que serán inoculados
pertenecen a las escuelas públicas de
igual forma en cada institución
educativa como está el ministerio de
educación el ministerio de la salud
manejará las listas de los estudiantes
que recibirán las dosis y que
posteriormente también para distribuir
brigadas médicas como estas que visiten
a las escuelas y se encargarán de la
vacunación que se realizarán tanto en
las escuelas públicas como las escuelas
privadas de igual forma el objetivo es
ampliar la vacunación en todo el
personal docente y de mantenimiento y en
las escuelas para generar la protección
necesaria sobre todo a la tranquilidad
por parte de los padres y representantes
que han expresado preocupación por el
retorno presencial a las aulas en las
clases en el país andino ante el nuevo
periodo de lectivo desde este año 2021
fue las que mantengan clases de manera
virtual deberán garantizar la presencia
de estudiantes en las fechas asignadas
de vacunación mientras que por la
población de 16 años ya se encuentran
vacunadas según cifras emitidas por el
gobierno ecuatoriano el poder anunció
que a partir del mes de enero podría
iniciar las vacunaciones de refuerzo o
terceras dosis de igual forma mientras
que no descarta aplicar en los niños
menores de 12 años a partir del próximo
año una vez obtenida más evidencia
científica en la actualidad en ecuador
se ha vacunado a más del 50% de la
población